did you ever know I never knew if you
knew no I really didn't oh this changes
I would have been a whole different
person
[Music]
in my book so I um I was very close to
my mother and my father and I um went in
and out of having some friendships
especially I tried more as I went to
college but we never really clicked and
you call him Elliot I call him Elliot
well now because he did something so
Unthinkable to me I I would never call
him dad again really so um I I get this
job on a film with Brandon Maxwell who
is I think that was his name it was
small but I thought my God I'm making a
film this story I can do this told my
father on the phone I got this audition
and I think I got this part and I'd give
him all this information he was curious
and next thing I knew they'd informed me
that FedEx letters were going
uh claiming I was a heroin addict
coincidentally I never was a heroin
addict and and I never tried it but you
know it was a real kind of poison pen
letter about me claiming to be an agent
and this went on they got like 11 in one
day 16 and another they told me and
eventually then they fired me before
even shooting and were lovely to me but
explained
we just don't know what's going on the
liability like we don't believe this but
are they going to be in our and people
take that seriously like that
explanation slot but I thought
it wasn't signed by me it was accusing
me and I didn't know where it was coming
from I had no idea where it was coming
from I thought maybe someone disliked me
in high school and this is happening but
who would know so anyhow later time goes
on I'm getting more and more afraid this
is going on in my life and then I hear
from a detective
said we know this is not you this is
like maybe almost a year later
still struggling but someone has been
writing letters to Drew Barrymore many
poison pen letters signed by Selma Blair
oh the Heartbreak I mean the fear the
horrible and eventually long story short
found out that it was my father someone
involved with my father and he was
letting this information get to her and
then when he found out it was her and I
said I can't you know he chose her and
didn't believe me I said no she's not
doing this you're you're also ruining
her life you put a Mickey in her drink
at Starbucks I mean just ridiculous
stuff I'm like I'm in New York I've
never met her but it was
I didn't know what I would do like this
was someone that was intent on doing
this and my father believed I don't know
so so that was it and he admitted at the
end I know what I did is wrong I know it
wasn't you and we never had a real
makeup I mean my whole adult life after
that once I found out it was him I had
to cut him out well good news it really
didn't get to me I really wanted to talk
to you about the documentary and it had
nothing to do with this I didn't even
know and then I found out about the
letters then I received your book and
then I was like okay yes I'm going after
her oh my God I love this I want to heal
this moment because
it wasn't real for me on my side nor
would I ever doubt you and actually have
been a total fan of yours on the side
like admirer for many many years it's
amazing the things we carry and what is
a trigger for us to feel totally
powerless because even though I was
aware I didn't do it it's like always
the fear anyone now trying to take away
credibility because it's all I have is
my truth I am honest now but what I have
to say to the audience that might not
know you were my childhood like favorite
because you were the girl well that's
why the letters went to you I assume
because he knew what you meant to me
really is that random oh I totally
thought it was random I was like oh this
is the part no one's no one's made the
clue and this is where I couldn't
and this makes more sense okay okay but
you were the favorite and I cannot tell
you how many people when I was little
was like you look like Drew Barrymore
and I was like you mean it and I I mean
it was such Joy it was such innocence
Joy of finding a kindred spirit through
books or movies you know to look at
that's all it was innocent and wonderful
talking about your book about the
experiences that you had because of
drinking I know I had them too
thank you and I'm talking about
that anyone even with their own messed
up mind can do anything they want to you
and the decisions you make and the
things you do
are not what you would do if you weren't
drunk did you tell yourself I put myself
here too yeah and it's only now from my
mother perspective when I hear how it
sounds for other girls listening and I
would never want them to feel this yes
we have a personal responsibility to
hope we can take care of ourselves but
unfortunately young people don't always
know how especially if they're parental
figures aren't exactly what you need for
your you know to teach you safety so how
did you find The Bravery to put it in
the book oh my God I was not going to I
was talking about it with Brittany who's
my dear friend and also my book agent
but I'm talking to her and I started
talking about this time in Florida how
much I was so excited to be invited
along with the Kappa Alpha thetas I was
not a sorority girl I transferred late
I'm on this trip with them and they're
all blonde and happy and their families
are checking in and I'm just the wild
child that's like driving them down
there and um
from Michigan and I sat down I remember
to kind of figure out where I was and
get my vision back it was like a day of
drinking on a boat and
um
and I was attacked it came on friendly
but it was attacked and there's two and
I was so sick I remember vomiting and
and I wouldn't cry and I I got back to
the place and um I had to just go on
with the day and go on a scuba diving
trip and knew I wouldn't tell those
girls because they would then I would
have to go to the hospital because they
probably knew that that's the right
thing and then what if I had a disease I
didn't want them to know I'd have to
find this out you know I thought I had
AIDS
I mean for a long time it was um and I
and I said to her oh God that's so
frightening I can't put that in the book
people will think oh my God who is this
person and she said but why why
can't you because I think that might
help people and I thought
really are there other
normal people thinking what's not that
that have let this happen that put
themselves there but when I'm reading
this not only am I in awe that you're
saying it because everything you just
said about the embarrassment I don't
want to tell my friends they might judge
me I put myself in this situation did I
deserve it if there's a real aftermath
I'd like to keep that to myself these
are demons for me to own
I did think about Arthur
and I thought about your son
and how you
you could be a mother that teaches a boy
I pray that that behavior is obviously
nowhere near acceptable I pray I do
teach him he doesn't know those parts he
has but he does know and I did tell him
that a teacher that I loved had
trespassed against me I want to tell him
that because it might happen to him I
mean it might happen to all of us and
and a friend of his I want to talk about
your mom speaking of critical I feel
like I would talk to myself probably the
way that your mom did
what was it like to grow up with that
voice there the things she said to you
are hard to fathom
I know you guys had this in love we were
in love too though how did you
process when you were a kid when your
mom would say these critical Things To
You O Selma you don't look good here or
it was her love language and I knew it I
knew even her insults were loved they
were attention
and if she could get around to saying I
was pretty to believing I was pretty I
did not think I had any other talent I
thought maybe I could write a book like
on a note card because she loved that
and but she did tell me you need to
write you need to write I will edit I
will edit and she's a very clear good
editor and I wish
I would have had the confidence to meet
her with her talents and my talents and
really create something but I had
different habits I didn't have it in me
um to find it that early I didn't
totally totally happily quit drinking
until she was far removed
like from my life so I didn't need it in
the way I wish I could know her I don't
know a thing about my mother I don't
know a thing
really I don't know what's true yeah I
don't know her who she was she would
kept it so close to the vest it was all
meant to disarm people and keep them
away but it was the kind of thing when I
was little and I said Mommy I'm gonna
write I'm gonna write this and maybe she
had had too much wine after dinner and
Elliot's across the way and she she said
oh no no no you are not you're not gonna
act you're not you're gonna we're gonna
pedal your beauty we'll pedal your face
and she was a woman who's a judge and
all she believed was doing things on
your own but she stayed with a man she
was very unhappy with because of that
time and we still believe it perhaps
that we are made better if a partner
believes that we are lovable and that we
are part of a group and she stayed in
this very unhappy marriage and I think
it's partly why she was kind of mean and
stayed out of the house in the house and
had no love they did not you know she
did not love him she resented him
and even though that woman was so
powerful to me she was still afraid of
living life as an independent woman did
you see that as a kid I could because
I'd say even young I'd say mom leave
leave and she'd say I can't he'll take
you he'll tell people I was in a mental
hospital when I was young he'll tell
people and she was wrongly put there and
all these things that I wound up
repeated she got a horrible virus and
somehow something happened and she like
regressed and couldn't talk and sad and
and then I think the doctor said she was
dying to her parents and made passes
that like it was a very different time
like living there away from the family
and then she got put away because I
think she was going to tell what
happened to her and then she got put
away and then she compartmentalized and
said I better never show that again
and she just lived
do you ever look at Arthur and say I
hope I could be the breaker
I hope I break this generational chain
and will it I mean I have so many family
secrets that I like need to tell you
because I think you're like a sounding
board that I haven't so what is like
sorry where's my coffee this is my
annotated worn and loved dog hair coffee
um
why do you choose
to put it all out there
it's so brave I need it
I love it how does one make the choice
if someone's watching and I always do
this as if nobody's ever watching but if
and when they are if they need
a takeaway of how to be brave to tell
their truth do you have any advice
all I can think is
today I have joy like I've never known
right now today with you
everyone might might not get to sit with
one of their favorite childhood people
and their favorite adult people there's
huge gifts we get but
I am I never thought I would have it and
it will be fleeting it might go and
today I could beat myself about
something but I won't I stop and I say
do you have a couple friends out there
like you really do so much and and
and you can breathe like it's changed
life will change
life will change and sometimes it will
be so scary
I wish I had someone that came down and
said when I was little
you will be okay
you will be okay and you will be able to
stop drinking
I mean I knew even at seven I don't
think I'll ever be able to stop
like that's the best thing when Diana
Ross and The Supremes comes on in the
background and I have a rum and coke in
me at the age of seven and a half and
like a little bit of mascara and my
older sisters are dancing and there's a
man over there looking at little me like
out of something
great memories of my childhood
like they were I don't want people to
fall into that trap that that
those moments of warmth are worth giving
up
giving up hope
I felt Hope For The First Time In Those
first sips and so you chase it the whole
night you chase the hope and warmth
but I didn't look for my own I had no
idea I had hope
until I saw my son and I love him more
than anything and I think oh God if he
started drinking right now or if he
started doing the hurtful things to
girls that people did to me what would I
do and loving to get them on track
because it's here right now
and I don't know I just have to say
breathe with me every night before bed I
can feel we're tense it's like okay
just breathe we love our kids the most
and we realize we want nothing to get in
the way of that once again my kids have
made me find the high road yes and I
travel oh no with will absolutely and
I've never had a reason
to make sure I was okay yes you want to
be told everything's going to be okay
like we craved that growing up
I will be the living example of
everything's going to be that's what I'm
hoping for them that's what I'm hoping
even for anyone that's a fan of yours a
fan of mine that remembers the hard
times it's like
we're here like
I'm okay with death I'm okay with living
I'm okay with living and like even I
heard it like Jimmy the Curtis saying it
on a podcast the other day but she was
like die alive and I was like who knew I
would ever say that wait legally brought
blonde three I'm really excited about it
I mean all amazing I've been so kind of
are you in if they
um yeah like as if I'd say no you know
like
I will say yes I will beg maybe secretly
quite of our you know like I'm thrilled
for a cameo see you and I I'm just one
of them either it's like I'm not like
one sure who wouldn't love like a part
but yeah I just want to be there I want
to enjoy it I want to see this movie
have this energy again because we we
need and love it too you know we really
do got lightning in a bottle with that
and I love that you're like that I'm the
same way when people are like a
Charlie's Angels three or you know when
people act koi about stuff I'm like I
know I'm like are you kidding I want to
be on that set I would go visit any set
Reese is doing and if I even got a cameo
but like any of us to be back you know
together like
it's so appreciated now like just at
this stage in my life I might not have
felt that 10 years ago like I might not
have understood where I was and now it's
like oh yeah these are the gifts these
are just the nice reconnects and if I
can grow up and be any part of that I'm
thrilled speaking of two women was it
true that there was a moment in Legally
Blonde that maybe Vivian Kensington and
Elle Woods were going to sail off into
the sun in my dreams like I didn't write
that but no someone had mentioned it
because someone erroneously thought so
but it did end originally
uh with us together and Vivian had
blonde hair yes and so it was like oh
I'm like blonde now too and I was like
we're the lawyers club and we were
friends we were obviously you know like
best friend ending but of course the
ending of her really moving and finding
her strength you know without anyone or
without changing any one thing as a
region that was clearly a ratio because
I know the wings and blue
who's your boyfriend yeah
yeah this is my 90s self-going nuts
because I'm like oh my God
so cute but in the reshoot he looks
totally different than he did oh totally
but yeah the acting I would love to come
back without guide Beauty I love that
you're a fan of this show we knew about
this the whole time we love guide Beauty
this was there's this woman Terry's
makeup artist wonderful friend and now
and she had Parkinson's and her hands
were really you know her body the
movements even though I'm doing great
with my MSN I'm in remission I still do
and when it's time to take medicine
again of this I do yeah like that it's
like a hiccup that comes up now that I'm
focusing on it it'll kind of come in and
it's different for everyone whatever so
I get speech and movement things a lot
of times I um like throw things and
don't mean to so this is like a good
balance near my eye it's a silicone nib
you know so it's like I try and put
eyeliner I love
but it's like they'll be the wood when
I'm doing it myself and someone can't
see what I'm doing it's like I'll poke
my eye I got a corneal abrasion and then
when I saw this and I stopped wearing
makeup and it felt kind of crappy to not
look in the mirror because I love that
it's inclusive design and it does not
have to separate you as oh there's your
your ramp over there and here's the way
everyone else does it it's like now
we're having a lot of infrastructure
rebuilt and rethinking and it's like why
can't we make the stages with like a
ramp included as we get older like you
are as bright as rain in my books thank
you as are you I love you and I try to
find The Bravery to tell it to but you
have forced
your way into my life in this course
field in this the Phoenix this force and
I just I not only like and love you I
I'm learning from you I'm in awe of you
I'm admiring thank you I've felt these
ways about you for so long you've been
doing it all along but but thank you and
it does mean so much I mean it means so
much to even
think with love now instead of fear
[Music]